(electronic music)
- Iman Shumpert, of the New York Knicks,
is in our kitchen eating cereal.
- Crazy.
- So we're gonna go interview him,
we're gonna leave right now, let's go.
- I'm happy you came to the show, man,
we're gonna play this little
game called Shump Says.
We're gonna give you a topic
and you give us some
quick thoughts on 'em.
- That's all we want.
- I'll tell you exactly
what Shump would say.
- Alright.
- So how do you feel
about the Brooklyn Nets?
- You know, great group of guys.
Cool black and white
jerseys and everything...
- They do have some cool jerseys.
- But they're the New Jersey Nets.
I just hate that Knick
fans are now Nets fans...
- Oh that's happening?
- Until we beat 'em and then
they're Knicks fans again.
- How do you feel about Rihanna?
- I love Rihanna, love you.
I don't need to know when
you walking down the street.
People in real life be
Tweetin' about this all day.
- Yeah.
- There be people on my
timeline talkin' about
what Rihanna's doin', don't care.
- What's some of your favorite
stuff to eat on the road?
- I like Rice Krispies Treats.
- What do you think of Rice
Krispies with chocolate chips?
- Nah.
- Yeah, me either.
- And how do you feel about
peanut butter and jelly
in the same jar?
- Pretty cool.
- So we have some Twitter questions
from some people from Twitter.
(chirping)
- So first question from @Winston_Wolfe:
"What's an unwritten rule that
basketball fans don't know?"
- If I pull out my
phone, they will fine me.
- Why will they fine you
for pullin' out your phone?
- It's unprofessional.
- Most professionals use phones, though,
like lawyers use phones
- This is basketball.
- @DonovanStrain says
"Your hi-top fade versus Norris Cole."
(bell rings)
I know the answer, I mean.
- His is what you expect.
- Yeah.
- He's just, box,
uh,
part.
- Unimaginative, you know.
- Like I knew you were gonna do that.
- Oh this is from @JaylaPlante, he said
"Can you hit us with the Kanye walk?"
- Oh, the Kanye walk.
- Yeah.
- He just hit 'em with the...
(laughs)
I don't know, that's
his thing now, you know.
- Yo, thanks for the (crosstalk).
- Thanks for the cereal, baby.
- This was dope.
- Cereal with Shump.
♫ The truth (banging muffles lyrics)
♫ Talk up my dude, I can't hear you
♫ Copy my every move like
(banging muffles lyrics)
♫ I'ma still excel while
you people in my rear-view
♫ Yeah, I'm cruisin' like a boat launch
♫ I'm close with the swish,
I don't smoke cigars boy
♫ I dropped my phone
♫ I chucked a three,
three of those to the dome
(instrumental music)